that lets you kind of um do interesting
calculations on the cloud on clusters um
on on Prem systems and any kind of
devices you have right from your python
setup um so just to take a stock over
here so how many of you people are
familiar with using an high compute
either on the cloud or on Prem or on
your laptop wherever
oh okay cool do you guys use in gpus for
ML training or anything of the sorts how
many of you are familiar with that
perfect awesome then this is a right set
of audience for us uh coming in okay so
just to start with let me set the stage
for why we think there needs to be a new
way of looking at um such tools coming
in uh just a decade ago or something you
know um you had this entire transition
of cloud era coming in so people from
on-prem system started moving things to
the cloud and that instigated a new set
of tools that needed to come in and you
can think of tools like kubernetes and
Docker that facilitated this transition
moving in from on Prem to you know uh
Cloud setup uh over there and then half
a decade or so ago the big term was the
big data so that involves collecting
large data and handling it and you know
working around with such kind of data
coming in and again new set of tools
came in for that examples are spark how
do you know you name it of course
everyone of you is expert over here in
Big Data so all those set of tools
coming in and then the current set of
era what we call as computa came in and
mostly driven by the needs of large
compute that is needed for either
machine learning or compute needed for
you know Niche set of things writing
from fpgas to ASX to gpus to even
quantum computers that we do work in
work with as well so these kind of new
systems are coming in and new paradigms
are coming in and there exists no such
tool which is dedicated towards
accelerating compute and facilitating
this compute speed up and this is very
critical because it comes in it with its
own challenge that you need to solve in
a good example of that um that you might
be familiar with is the lack of GPU
access on the cloud so if you want to
access hunds let's say or even a00 on GP
you need to wait an long time in the
queue and typically kubernetes and other
things won't handle large qes and these
calculations may run in for couple of
days or hours together while you know
kubernetes or Docker or meant for things
that are more IO bound more you know
scaling apps and those kind of setup and
people typically in the academic side
use are familiar with these kind of high
performance tools and one of the example
is let's say if you have worked with
slum schedulers PBS lsf these kind of
schedulers are truly maintain for
running in high performance jobs with
large cues large time to access in but
these don't exactly translate into a
pythonic world or a cloud World these
are more typically meant for running in
jobs and you know National Labs huge
clusters and those set of things so our
way of thinking about is to come up with
these kind of um you know to solve these
kind of problems in with new tools that
is more native towards what the the
language that people use in which is
python in and that's where we you know
came up with this open source tool
called calent on our side and I let ARA
introduce what exactly covalent is on
its
end um okay hello I hope everyone can
hear me okay um
so like santor said uh calent is an
orchestration tool for high compute um
and what it does for you is it connects
you to uh any Patchwork of resources
that you have available to you in in a
really convenient and generic way right
out of your own uh python environment so
if you have access to um AWS or Google
cloud and even if you have some sort of
GPU cluster or a slurm cluster on the
side as long as you have the credentials
get into those things there's a way to
unify all that um with calent in a way
that's super convenient for you to use
and super modular so you can swap out
different tasks going to different
places uh Etc BR in my way just to add
on to it at any point this is a tutorial
not a talk so if you have any questions
or any feel free to you know inter
interrupt us any point and uh you also
see a quantum computer over there so we
do connect to Quantum computerss as well
so if that's a point of interest for you
get in touch with me I can talk more
about it ah yeah um and a big sort of uh
selling point for calent although we're
talking about the open source version
for now um is just a heterogenity so uh
no matter what sort of resource you have
in the back you can plug it into calent
and work with it in a lightweight and
convenient way um so you can do CPU CPU
jobs GPU jobs um if you're using Quantum
you can also get into qpu and it's all
unified in one place and that place is
coent uh the last Point down here coent
cloud is um our fully managed offering
which is the based on the open source
version we'll get into that um towards
the end of the presentation more uh but
for now we'll take a look at just open
source coent what it's like to work with
it and some of the stuff that it can do
for
you so here's a maybe a first look at
what the user experience is like so um
you can see we have a little decorator
that's denoting
this uh train SPM function in this case
has something called an electron um
that's just the word we use for tasks
and when I say calent is convenient and
modular we understand that we can pass
this electron something we call an
Executor in this case in this little GIF
it's just passing a string so it'll be
the default config that you have for uh
any one of these platforms that you see
see it cycling through here yeah so just
to add on to it what this does is
essentially you have a function that you
want to ship it somewhere um you can
test it locally say you just have 10
data that you want to check it locally
in your laptop you can do it in and once
you are fine with it you can pass this
function to any kind of compute backend
on your be AWS ec2 instance batch
instance on slum cluster you have an
access to SSH machine on your system
with SS credential you can just pass it
by passing on your executor and this
will exactly take care of packing your
inputs packing your function submitting
it out there calculating the outputs
storing the output in a metadata getting
it back and everything that happens in
the background for you without you doing
anything on
sorry so um oh this used to be white oh
what happen to my title there okay this
says customize executors to run tasks V
yeah so a little bit more fleshed out
version of the gift back here you can of
course um you know customize the
execution environment as well so if
you're working with AWS batch you can
specify the resources you want um the
time limit and as well as any
dependencies that your task might have
that you want to be available in the VM
uh that actually ends up running uh the
particular task uh this thing on the
right is just an example with a
different executor so in this case maybe
you're targeting a slurm cluster
somewhere and uh you have your
credentials but also like the um sort of
the options you would see in a slurm
script you can specify here as just um
just parameters in a
dictionary um so what you would do with
both of these things is like you see
down here you just pass this object to
The Decorator and that will make your
task run on uh the executor that's
specified by that
object man I've lost a lot of text
here I'm going to make that
white guess something happened when I
pasted it into
the there we
are okay so just to kind of uh pitch on
a point on for this current audience
where would covalent be useful as the
title in the tutorial suches
so essentially the one of the major use
case that we have seen people using Co
valent for or two folds one is
essentially using covalent as a backend
for any kind of high performance app
that you write in so if you need in your
app any kind of GPU computer or CPU
compute or any intensive compute that
you need to have it in and you need to
write your code in a way that it's
agnostic to the backend or the compute
back end that you're sending it to be it
AWS a or gcp or any kind of system so
you write your code in calent and you
just tag along it and you can scale it
up or scale it down how much you want
and send it to any kind of compute if
you're using coent as a backend for your
compute so the setup that people
typically have been having is shown over
here so you have your application code
that sits over here which is I guess um
anything that is being llm or generative
a or any kind of application that you
want to write in and you essentially
decorate that functions with a single
line of decorator and it ships it off to
co valent to compute and use any kind of
compute backend that you need to do on
the entire orchestration is abstracted
from you on your end while you writing
the application in so this essentially
splits the work if you have a team into
two sets of things one is the researcher
who actually or the data scientist who
actually develops the code in and the
platform engineer essentially just you
know slaps along a decator on top and
say hey I need these to run on AWS I
need these to run on gcp or wherever you
want to swap it in and one of the pretty
neat and interesting thing is that we
have plugins and this way that you swap
in the execu is by plugin system so you
can write your own plugins as well so we
have seen people writing plug plugins to
you know GPU clouds that exist in alt
GPU clouds that give you very cheaper
access to gpus like 50 90% of the cost
that you would get out of typical Cloud
providers so to connect to these guys
without changing your actual business
code is pretty useful and that's why we
have seen most of the people um using
coent for on this side
um and the Second Use case that we have
seen is more over to the moving on from
the production app to a more research
phase happening in typically while
researching a lot of training in model
and other things the setup that you have
is you write a python script you write
write a shell script if you're doing it
an on-prem to send it somewhere on an
SSH machine or wherever you are sending
it in but you open up an E2 instance or
VM and then submit your script run your
script wait until it trains and then see
if there are any errors and then redo it
iterate it and do all those sort of
things so where covalent helps in is
that even when you're researching on
your side from jupyter notebook you just
slap along once you're done it locally
testing everything slap along a single
decorator and it does ships it to the
cloud for you to do the computer in and
as AR will shown we have a live
monitoring UI that lets you monitor the
code asset runs in live and you can
cancel it redispatch it swap it change
parts of your module and anything you
want right from your local laptop and
all those changes will reflect back in
the cloud environment that you are
working on so that lets it pretty fast
to iterate um you know your research go
throughout without even interacting with
any kind of AWS console or gcp console
or anything you have in your hand or
even without writing a single line of
script um on your end
take all right so this is uh whenever we
talk about calent this is a slide that
people usually ask in like why do I need
to use covalent instead of a b and c so
this is where uh we fit in so to give a
broad overview of this you know again
going back to the chronological era
decade ago or something parallelization
was pretty important and you had these
kind of tools like you know JBL syon n
and p the goal here is to kind of you're
given a single PC and you want to
distribute your code throughout this
multiple core system coming in so that
was the main motivation for these kind
of paralyzation tools that comes in and
then you had these distributed
computation tools so the goal is not
only to I have one PC with me I have
multiple PCS with me and now I need to
distribute my code throughout these PCS
and you know work around with it and
then you had these tools like dask
Rapids you know Ray and all those really
nice tools U over there putting a pause
and going to the topmost tool then you
had in your goal was not only to
distribute these things but you kind of
need to run it in a periodic order and
you have to combine this data pipelines
to make very complicated workflows
coming out of your system and typically
these things run in the cloud and
production environment things like
running it in Netflix uh recommendation
system or you know um shopping
recommendation system and those kind of
things and then you had these workflow
tools that came in like prefect dager
airflow Luigi and all these really
interesting tools and where we sit in
the stack is distributed workflow setup
so Our intention is to have a workflow
but it's much more geared towards
compute in the sense that each part of
your task is indeed a computer intensive
or not so computer intensive part that
you want to distribute to various kind
of Hardwares coming in and that's
exactly where our for Tye hats in and
you can use any of these tools along
with our tool as well so we internally
use D cluster as default to distribute
our stuff but you can swap it to Rapids
or Ray or anything that you want on an
end and you can use it within our code
tool as well to do it in so let me just
pause here and see if you have any
questions coming
in perfect
go yeah um so just to kind of uh give
you an example the kind of classical
okay so you see classical resources over
here because we also support quantum
Computing and there was a part for
Quantum Resources but ignoring that the
classical resources we support right now
or slum if you're familiar with high
performance clusters that exist in
National Labs
AWS all kind of AWS uh services like
fargate batch Lambda ec2
eks um you know you name it Azure we do
every Service as well gcp bad kubernetes
you can spin up a kubernetes cluster and
ship it over there as well dask IBM
systems You Name It We have plugin
system for all of these things and you
can just install it and start shipping
your code wherever you want and as far
as the software packages go we are
pretty agnostic to the software package
you use in because the package your enti
function together so as long as it's
pickable and we have written a lot of
custom serialization on top of it which
means everything that we have tested
right now our serialization is able to
do except for pretty Niche things so we
are pretty agnostic to any kind of
package you use inside the codin
currently even though the workflow or
the task you write in is uh restricted
to be in python in the sense that you
need to write in Python functions inside
those python functions we have given
abstractions to write in cc++ bash code
if you want to A bash command over there
for if you're running parallel MPI open
m those kind of setup and we are
planning to add in support for Julia as
well as time goes back but for now
Python cc++ and Bash tasks are allowed
inside the each independent tasks compan
in yeah yeah all right go here okay um I
guess I'll give a sort of the high level
review of the ux of just using calent um
there's two main things you want to
concentrate on so uh here's a little
mockup of like a workflow graph on the
right the terminology here is going to
be each task we call an electron and the
entire graph we refer to as a lattice
that's the two terms you need to
remember and corresponding to that so if
I have my python code um I have a task
here called task um in order to make
that a task in my workflow I just add
this decorator on top and then um I can
use that task in another main function
or something like that and I put lattice
on top of that to indicate that this is
going to be the workflow
function then the third major piece is
just dispatching the workflow so one
cool thing about coent is that if you
don't want to actually run this on
whatever remote compute um it's totally
non-destructive when you add these
decorators so if you just call the
function normally it'll run normally um
nothing's been broken however if you
want to actually send it off to whatever
resources you've specified in that case
you just wrap it in cq. dispatch um pass
the inputs and there you go yeah and one
thing to add is this is one of the
problems that you face in high compute
environment compared to low compute
model training or something is that
typically when you're running a code
model training or something it might
take in couple of hours or even days in
certain cases so this asynchronous call
of sending it to a cloud system getting
an ID back and then requiring it
whenever you need is a pretty critical
part to have and so for instance ARA
Works in a lot of research problems
which takes in couple of days to compute
on bunch of GPU missions and it's almost
impossible to you know keep a notebook
live for couple of days or even if
you're sending in a script it's pretty
hard to maintain that script and you
know reiterate it over so this these are
the things that makes uh working with a
high compute environment different than
working with a low compute environment
which is what the need is turning
towards when especially in the AIML case
when you want to train
stuff okay and we'll take a much more in
depth look at this stuff yeah we'll be
running into tutorials working with llms
uh um you know some kind of um General
machine learning stuff and getting
started as well uh but just wondering um
how many of you want to follow in
together for the tutorials uh there's a
GitHub link over there as well that you
can work with the tutorials with all the
notebooks and everything on that side uh
but if you can just raise your hands if
you want to follow up we can wait along
with it or we can just show you the
tutorials running
in all right sweit I guess we can just
go in sure
okay
um all right so the first thing I'll
show you guys is the bare minimum calent
workflow uh so this is also in our docs
on our website um actually if you go to
Just calent doxyz you can find
everything from there there's our slack
our GitHub um and what I'll be showing
you is just a quick start from our
docs CL this one yeah thank you is the
font a reasonable size everyone is that
okay can zoom in a little a little bit
more bit
more that
better
okay um so if you do want to uh you know
go along with
this um you can just scan this uh QR
code here or even this one this one will
take you to the repo this is the
specific
notebook um just uh clone the repository
the environments and everything is set
up in there um if you don't want to do
it right now you can even run it later
there should be instructions for
everything
okay and the other thing to do is to
just make sure we have Co valent running
my case I'll just type in Cove valent
status good to go
okay uh let me zoom out temporarily just
to see the entire cell
here so like I was saying just a little
while ago we have electrons we have the
lattice and we have dispatching and
getting the the result back here's a
really tiny um actually trivial workflow
U the only tests in here are adding
multiplying and dividing there's nothing
interesting really happening I'm just
going to add these numbers here multiply
them in the next one and divide them in
the other uh you can see that each of
those functions is labeled as an
electron so this is going to be
considered a task in my
workflow and down here I have my
workflow function it doesn't need to be
called workflow by the way uh you can
obviously call it anything you want uh
this is labeled as the lattice so this
is what I'm going to run uh through
calent in this case let's take a look at
what it's doing real quick um this
number is going to be the addition of X
and Y R2 is going to be just a list full
of multiplications and R3 is going to be
a list full of
Divisions the interesting part about uh
all that is that calent will actually
figure out how all these different tasks
are interrelated in terms of the
dependencies of the the inputs of one to
the outputs of the
other um so you can see it's completed
we have our little result object that
I'm printing here um R3 will be attached
to this object but you can see
everything's done some of the outputs on
the nodes and if I go over to my
UI which you can find by in the co
valent by default when you run it
locally it opens up a server over here
in the local host and that should give
you a pretty neat UI for enti workflow
that lets you monitor the different
tasks and different um you know jobs
that you are sending it out to the cloud
or local on your side okay and the sort
of the centerpiece of the UI when you
look at a particular workflow is is this
directed ayli graph that it generates um
in this case it's quite simple right so
there is one node on which um the next
layer of four nodes Depend and then each
of those depend on another none of this
was explicitly specified um in our lat
function but the way things are set up
Co actually understands the dependencies
here so in this example there's really
uh no way to cheat at the very top you
have to run this one function uh but
once we get to the second layer of this
graph um it's already been understood
that these tasks are completely
independent so the paralyzation there
will happen automatically just right out
of the box uh in this case it's
happening in a Das cluster that covalent
starts on my laptop but uh if any one of
these tasks was sent to a different
Source it would work exactly the same
way yeah so just to add to it uh I guess
we just wrote a blog post pretty
interestingly on um running a federator
learning model which spins up um each of
these tasks runs on AWS gcp and AER
together and combines the model together
in a local instance so in that scenario
your local laptop will be the central uh
for your Federated learning and each
individual task will spin up new
missiones calculate it combine to the
local one spin it down and then go to
the next iteration and start it and so
all these parations are extremely useful
when it comes to multicloud setup or
even individual Cloud running on
multiple GPS on your side as
well yeah and uh another cool thing
about the UI is that it sort of just
keeps everything here in a record um
unless you clear it obviously but um so
I don't have to reopen my Jupiter
notebook I don't have to reopen vs code
set up my environment again or do
anything really because I can just come
in here click on a specific task I can
copy the output right there um uh what
this does is actually copies a little
snippet of code that will load this into
um whatever python object yeah you just
paste this into a python script or like
a jupyter notebook and assign the uh
whatever comes out of the clipboard here
and then you'll just get the object
there in this case it's just an integer
that says six but potentially it's
something more interesting um which
actually we'll show you in a
bit there also you can do the same with
the inputs as well um and with the
inputs to the entire lce function so the
the workflow function previously it's
all there for you um yeah and there's a
couple other things that you can play
around with like yeah and pretty cool
feature that I don't think we speak
about over here is once you have this
workflow you can essentially redispatch
this workflow with new inputs without
requiring any of the additional
dependencies or installations that's
needed from any Mach so if you have a
high Computing job that you already
shipped it to a bunch of GPU resources
and you you want to spin off this entire
workflow right from a Lambda function or
a cloud function that you want to spend
it but just new inputs you don't need
your entire package of f Tor or anything
installed in that Lambda function you
can just pass on the new input and say
with the dispatch ID hey redispatch this
again with a new idas and you can get
back the results so you can have it as a
very scalable backend with submitting
new inputs to a huge set of uh server
and the server will take care of
spinning up all the resource and
installing everything that you needed on
the
background
mhm and uh if you question could you
please uh show the example how it will
work if uh we will have divide by zero
so oh you error out yeah so he probably
has already an error on the
side yeah um so you see the task has
failed in side and if you go to the UI
yeah that just failed with them yeah
they were identical so I ran this node
four times you can see here um I'm
running the divide function four times
inside this list and it depends on the
uh outputs from the previous list but
since they're all dividing by zero um
they all fail you get your little error
right here yeah and you can do pretty
interesting things this actually reminds
me like uh we do support the concept of
dynamic graphs so what that means is um
your graph result your graph can be
built based on the result of the
previous one so if for instance you say
this one errored out and you want to do
something else grow your graph in some
other way based on this error out you
can do that as well and we have seen
people use it for pretty interesting
things like um on the- flight um you
know choice of resource that they want
to have in so they make query on which
gpus are the cheap in the cloud and then
ship it to that kind of gpus on the Fly
after 2 days or 3 days if the task are
running in all that side so we do
support Dynamic um graphs as they expand
in okay and do do you have any support
for developing electrons so how do you
develop the the function the electron
because
I don't know you have some workflow for
developing the the function that will be
run as electron oh that's up I mean is
this maybe I'm not is this is the way
you write in an electron on your side
like the okay is see a question like is
there a workflow to so the workflow I
don't know can you ship in as WR
packages on top is that what you mean
because you know it's very hard to to
write the the the the good code that
will be run on some I don't know big
machine
and how how do you write this small
chunk of of code that will be running
well ideally you just write a function
and pretend it's going to work um and
usually it does so the things you want
to worry about is setting up the
environment correctly um I'll show that
in maybe the second notebook maybe a
more full- flesh llm example would work
in but we do have so for instance if
your question is uh we do have people
who have written packages on top of
calent to U so for instance there was a
person from Berkeley writing in quantum
chemistry codes on top of it which
requires a lot of Compu on its end and
from his package you can just import
calculate energy of molecule and that
will be an electron in itself that he
has written in a very clean way that you
can just use it inside of your code and
in theory you could have train llm as an
electron that you have written out and
stored in a package itself that you can
start using it to form workflows so the
ideal setup is that people write
packages on top of Co valent to either
expose electrons which are just tasks in
your thing that you then construct your
workflow in or a pipeline in or people
have written pipelines in itself on top
of calent where an entire thing is a
pipeline in itself um so you have this
entire graph in itself being shipped out
as a and can can I use the electron
function in unit test yes yeah so this
outside of Co valent context it behaves
as a normal python function in any way
that's one of the main thing in fact
which I missed is one of the key things
we wanted to have is to write unit test
on top of these things so every electron
and lce that you see here is a normal
python function outside of coent context
so it behaves as a I can just I mean you
can just call in so you know if I pull
that out and I have workflow of so hard
Tope onea two okay oh you okay yeah but
it just behaves as a normal runs the
function right python function so there
you go um so nothing should change until
until you ship it to a calent server and
that server can be hosted in your laptop
or Cloud machine or whever it is on your
side here it's running in this local
laptop until you ship it there it
behaves as a normal python function on
your end okay yeah um and as far as like
special considerations it probably
depends where you're sending the
function but usually there's not much to
think about um if you're referencing a
local file and this task is going to run
in a cluster somewhere then obviously
the file is not going to exist so stuff
like that you have to keep in mind but
um part of the design is that it's all
all you do is just specify the electron
and then the the function is whatever
the function is up to you and just to
add on to this as well we have
abstractions for you to transfer file
from your local machion to wherever
machine you are sending it in Asal so if
you have your training data in your
local machion or in an S3 bucket or
whatever it is we have abstractions
probably can show it in over here let me
see
so oops it's other way around so you can
just add into say that hey I need to
transfer a remote file from my source
path to destination using rsync or I
want to transfer it from using um S3
Bucket from I don't know blob over here
uh Microsoft blob with a strategy of
with my you know client Daddy and secret
and this transfers your file before your
electron runs in the main machine and
once it's completed transfers it back
wherever you wanted to asold so there
are different abstractions for you to
make it easy to work on a remote machine
right from your lap toop and that's the
theme throughout this uh you know OS
code base it's it has all the
abstractions you need to run your python
functions in any kind of compute backend
on your side with a single decorator on
it side oh another question oh yeah yeah
so when you specify local is that using
like just synchronous execution threats
multi-processes that's a great question
so by default we use Das cluster spin up
a Das cluster wherever this is running
in but if you don't want to use a Das
cluster we support multiprocessing uh as
well the problem with multiprocessing is
it doesn't handle memory really good on
its side so that's why we spin up a dask
cluster by default and one of the
example you will see is that um we will
right now in the tutorial spin up a dask
cluster on the remote and use that as a
backend for our coent but by default
it's been up a d cluster on its um local
environment that you
on so just as like an examp I haven't
used that very much but for for
illustration um if you have a directory
of images and you want to resize every
image together one of the things you
could do is just like open it in open CV
resize it and then save it is that the
kind of thing you do
in yeah yeah that's F so in fact I think
what was the ml example in dask that you
running in um it's not resizing I think
I have a llm describing yeah describing
so what he does is instead of resizing
he runs a he has an folder of images
which we'll run in the tutorial and read
through the image and use all them to
describe it but that's pretty much the
same yeah
uh yeah that's what people use it in for
as well yeah actually there's a cool
feature in the second notebook that's
sort of relevant to that um oh yes we do
have the concept of triggers as well to
trigger your workflow based out of any
event that happens pick that real quick
um um yeah there really lot of nice
features that I don't think you're going
in on this one but um okay here's an
example so I guess this will you are
attaching a trigger to your lats over
here to say that uh Hey trigger this
workflow whenever this is a directory
trigger whenever an create event which
is like creating a new file and this
trigger happens and ship new batch size
of two recursively to all the setup and
we have SQL based trigger so if you have
a new entry in SQL you can trigger a
workflow of that um what else do we have
we have time based trigger so you can
trigger your workflow every 10 seconds
or in a crown or what yeah does it do
caching for that as well oh yeah yeah
everything is so by default everything
is completely cached in Co valent you
can turn it off but every every data
input output file everything is cached
by default and that where it caches it
typically caches in a local folder but
that could be an S3 bucket or any kind
of storage that you want to have it in
that you can config does that mean you
have to use hashable
inputs uh no because we serialize
everything on our side it doesn't need
to be you can any python object it
doesn't we don't care about it so it
could be an image object P image on your
case whatever it is um that that was one
thing we are very strict on is that user
doesn't need to think about the fact
that you're running it in calent you
just write any normal function and you
add it on top and it works automatically
except for there are very few Niche
things that is not pickable with our
serialization one example is um typical
boto clients or gcp clients are not
pickable because of the security
credentials on its side but you can work
around it by in instantiating inside the
function and that will work in as well
so we haven't seen any major problem
with pickling or using this setup in our
site yet on our
end
yeah okay so let not jump too far ahead
come back
here let me just rerun this one more
time just for a fun
okay um so I guess the another Point
here is that if you have this dispatch
ID handy um you can do this get result
call at anytime right so this is
completely independent from uh doing the
dispatch um as as long as it's cached as
long as you haven't purged all your
coent files or anything it doesn't
matter where the workflow ran the
results are brought back and safe for
you so um as long as you have coent
running as I do doesn't even have to be
running locally uh you can just do a get
result request uh to coent and pass it a
dispatch ID get everything back and you
have this result object with a bunch of
information um as well as the actual
return value um of the function there I
just rerent it but that's okay yeah so
um
I guess that's all uh as far as the
intro um of course if you go in and
rearrange this function the graph will
look different and all that yeah and one
thing to add is uh this is a very
scalable graph in the sense that we have
tested close to 10K nodes or 50k nodes
on our end and everything remains fall
tolerant and completely stable on our
side so it's not just meant for you know
piping in small chains of data flows on
its side but really huge craft that you
can handle in on this
set okay and on that note I think we can
move on to a more substantive
tutorial um okay so this one uh we're
going to use calent with a remote desk
cluster instead of uh having it spin one
up on our own
machine um and to set up the dask
cluster I've included in the tutorial
actually uh if you navigate to the repo
um this is number two um so you can see
here um reference to a readme file over
here um there's a readme in that in
there uh the terraform isn't really the
point of this I'm just going to run a
little set up to make the infrastructure
in AWS and we'll see how how to work
with it
okay so I will just do that real quick
here oh
Zoom is that better
Y where am
I um if you guys have has anyone work
with terraform before here oh yeah yep
okay um so it's it's uh how would you
describe I guess an infrastructure is
code tool um so what I'm doing here is
just making a couple ec2 instances on a
AWS I'm going to have one be the Das
scheder and the other ones be the desk
workers there's nothing fancy it's going
to be all static it's just going to sit
there and I'm going to have uh just an
address that I can plug into Cove valent
um so to do that you need a little ter
for
minute uh going to copy the code from
the read me
actually it
out okay and if I have my
credentials set up for AWS that should
just take a couple minutes there yeah
and do its thing so this here we are
creating a remote dask cluster to run it
in and one of the um feature request
that we have been asked a lot of time is
typical inducers for the calent or data
scientists you know research engineers
and other folks coming in so they're not
familiar with terraform or not that adap
that terraform or spinning up Cloud
resources and other setup so what we
have in the next set of releases in the
open source is that you can essentially
do calent deploy AWS batch and if you
have your credentials right it will
automatically spin up an entire batch
cluster on your side without you even
doing anything on AWS um and you can
start start using it right for your
workflows in your setup so all this even
working with terraform to spin up your
infrastructure will be abstracted out to
make it easier for you and what that
means is you don't need to even touch
anything in terraform or Cloud can
directly start using it in right from
your terminal on your side so that will
be pretty neat to have it and so we have
it on AWS batch gcp batch and Azure
batch coming in couple of months from
outside yeah um and also what you're
seeing now is um I screwed up had a typo
in the doc switch I will update so that
quote should be all the way here so just
give me a second to undo that
um yeah anyone any questions while this
is running in oh yeah could you go a
little bit more in depth like for
example I was executer and I have
dependencies in a
certain perfect yeah sure um can you go
to the dogs um
yep so
oh oh I don't know why this
is
okay
um okay so the way you kind of uh Define
dependencies uh in your cluster is we
allow for multiple essentially deps
dependencies on your side you can have
dips pip dips K uh dips bash which means
you need to run a bash script before
running your task and and you also
provide hooks for defining custom python
function to run before your function or
after your function so let's say you
have certain dependencies on your side
for to run a numpy so you need to
install numpy in this remote machine
running in so what you need to do is add
in a quags called dip spip and you just
say hey uh you can either pass in an
enti requirements. txt file for that or
you can just say my packages or nump is
what I need to install on that side and
what this will do is this will
essentially before running your function
install everything over here run your
function and then T it down or you can
even provide uh for some weird reason
let's say you want to install it after
you run your function or you want to do
very custom thing after you run your
function maybe you want to delete
credentials in it or ship that um you
know take the files and put it somewhere
else so we do provide call before and
call after hooks for you to pass on any
python function over here or even any
dependencies over here to be executed
before or after your function runs
actually I'm pretty sure you can just
pass the string as well you yeah you can
just yeah you can just pass your string
in so here you can just pass a list of
dependencies over here as well just like
I guess that's how har would have done
it on a
side yeah um so that installs is it
here yeah so I'm a list of yeah just
literally so this one needs below torch
torch fishion Transformers and you just
pass it as dips over here that's it and
this will install it right before your
function runs in in the BM and yep good
you can you also specify which I don't
have to oh yeah you can so we do provide
bash depths as well so you can edit
anything that you want
um yeah uh bash dependencies here it is
so you can send in any kind of commands
that you want to set in before your
setup so if you want to change your
Source change your python file change a
variable you can just do it there as
well uh one thing I haven't mentioned is
this what this means is this is
typically useful this gips Peppers is
typically useful if you're are iterating
as a researcher trying in various
packages and other things but once you
are done and you want to send it to
production it's typically not useful to
install everything before your task runs
in that's not ideal so what you can do
is for our cloudbased plugins um
executors you can attach any custom
images you have on your side as well so
if you have an image a container that's
pre-loaded with all the packages already
installed in it you can pass the image
and that way you shouldn't that's
typically for production on your side if
you want to convert it
yeah oh man I really oh it's taking it
spe yeah it's taking us pretty
surprising is just he tried it yesterday
and it took him like 28 seconds to spin
up these new things yeah cuz uh I
botched it and I destroyed it right away
so now now it's getting all confused um
but this is terraform not calent okay
just everyone blame terraform for this
uh I might actually just oh great okay
um so yeah this that quote should be
there okay
um
too many too
many um
really I screw up double
bar maybe just should apply for
us you can do bar
twice um I don't know why doesn't like
that expected at most one propositional
argument never go with live
demo um oh I'm sorry okay okay hang on
um sorry sorry this should be the plan
and then yeah
okay man I must have been really sleepy
when I made that read me
um uh out f. TF
plan in terraforms defense if I was be
doing this manually I would this would
take like 30 minutes so it's a lot um
there we go okay
sweet so now we actually wait for it
sorry guys uh does anybody have any uh
any other questions maybe yeah while
this is running I guess um for the
Curious view I can show in the kind of
plugins we have in um so we do have dask
we have sssh that lets you connect
through on Prem GPU systems or any ssch
you typically run your code in and for
that just to kind of see the ux it's
like you can set defaults in the
configuration so that you don't need to
pass on anything and you can just say
hey run it in SSH and it use the
defaults that you are passing it in but
if you actually want to pass on object
you can say that this is my username
host name here's my remote directory I
want to store my results or whatever uh
assets that develop in and then here's
my SSH key and then just tap it along
and that should be the SSH um slum again
for HPC or uh HPC users we have a list
of AWS plugin you know ec2 ec2 is pretty
interesting it will spin up a new ec2
instance on its own run your code shut
it down you don't need to do anything
and this interaction is as simple as you
know um just say hey I need an E2 off
instance this typ with this volume and
here my key it'll take care of spinning
up everything on the background you
don't even need to work with terraform
Lambda it's pretty neat as well if you
want to run Lambda functions you just
say um here's my Lambda function name
here's my S3 bucket to store all the
input and outputs pass it on and it will
spin up Lambda function for you so Cloud
execut Azure ignore these things these
are quantum Computing executors it's
IBM's Quantum plug-in KCET uh Amazon has
bracket service for Quantum uh you know
the thing and we do have um contributor
plugin uh that lets in any kind of HPC
system that they have in people in nurk
uh which is the Berkeley lab they use
calent as well and they have made their
own plugin to with their cluster on its
side and we do let you create your own
custom plugins as well you just copy
this template and to give you an example
of um how easy it is to create your own
plug-in let's look at one of the
contributor plug-in um and it's at the
most I would say you know 500 to 400
lines of code for you so the reason
people would do it is if you have a very
uh unique system on your hand that you
need to connect to maybe your SSS system
needs multiactor authentication because
you working in a private setup so this
lets you write your own plugin in how
much ever you want and we have you just
need to override a couple of functions
to write your own plugin U yes I was
going to ask how the the file
abstraction works if you can accept like
S3 buckets or Dynamo databases or
something yeah key and deletion
management looks very different from
local resources what do yes uh we don't
do Dynamo yet uh but we do have S3 and I
can show you an S3 example over here
oops there's the
um okay okay so let's see
S3 okay so here it is
um this is the ux you have so the you
define a strategy and typically the
parameters you pass in for your
credentials go into the strategy so let
me see if there is an example of
credentials being passed
to okay we don't have the credentials
being passed on but typically this
contains all the credentials and
everything that goes to the S3 transfer
and then you say hey I need to transfer
my file from my source path to final
path using this strategy and you can
even pass the order to say that do I
need to do it before the task or after
the task has been completed on its end
and you just tag along to say that hey
these are the file transfers I need it
to happen so I have two transfers one by
default I guess before the task and one
I say after the task so before the task
I pull in something from the S3 do some
computation over there and transfer it
back to S3 after it's done and uh just
to kind of and that will be the same for
remote blob storage here is an example
of blob withd so just like how you in
the S3 you would have something like
this to pass your credentials or keys or
whatever you want to pass it on and
pretty much the same intact over here
and this again all of this are modular
and we provide abstraction so if you
have very custom Dynamo DB you want to
extend it to Dynamo DB you just subass
the strategies and write your own custom
setup however you want it to on your
side
yeah um let's see if it's oh it's doing
there
okay um okay so it's outputed a schedu
address for me um this is just the
public IP of the ec2 instance that's
going to be the dash scheduler um and a
port
number I'm just going to copy
that let's go into the
notebook okay so by default we use dask
Asel locally so AR will now show how to
use a custom executor object to change
your attributes
mhm um okay I'll actually just go
through this cell by cell just so we and
what is the what is the thing we are
doing in this experiment what is the uh
we're going to so here's a little
preview um I have these two folders um
this is my triggered folder this is uh
the one I've set up to be the triggered
folder and when I drag and drop images
in here so maybe this is part of like I
I don't know you have some pipeline you
have some pipeline yeah there's there's
images coming in that need analysis you
have an M model that can do that that um
and you want that to happen
automatically but you know only when
there's new images you don't want to
waste time rerunning that over and over
uh so what I'm going to set up here is a
really simple version of that anytime
someone drags in uh two images which is
also a parameter so if I put in two
images into this new folder it will
trigger a workflow um it will analyze
them and it's going to write a short
oneline description in this at the
moment empty file um that's what we're
going to see here and the reason that
you would typically want to use coent
for this uh example is
so for instance one of our customer
using the open source has a huge
petabyte of video file on his side and
every time an experimental list uploads
a paby of this video file there's a
pipeline of machine learning process
that needs to transform this every time
happening in and typically that
conversion requires five or six gpus to
run together on a side so you can't have
a five or six gpus running on the cloud
every time to just tap along so this
takes care of spinning up a new instance
in this case we using a dask cluster
which is already running but this could
be SWA for any kind of executor runs and
it'll spin up a GPU just for this file
run it in close it and call it a day so
he has a huge saving in caused by just
spinning up GPU whenever it's needed on
a okay I'll just walk through the
notebook here um nothing special going
on here uh this is going to be what the
descriptions look
like um one thing to note here is that
you can also use like other code with
calent you don't need to decorate
everything with lates or electrons um so
I have a bunch of utility functions I'm
just going to use them normally and the
whatever task they get wrapped up in
that I actually want to send that's the
one I Mark um it's going to take care of
all this uh it'll be wrapped up and sent
in um and ran remotely just fine um this
is going to load the model for hugging
face I'm using a pre-train model to do
things quickly here um here's just some
filter functions and uh class for the
image and description so I can
manipulate it and show it to you guys at
the end of The
Notebook um okay so here's the first
electron this is the first task in my
workflow it's it's a lightweight task um
I'm going to run it in a local process
pool and so I've specified local here um
what is this doing is it's looking
through that
directory uh that's just the constant at
the very top it's going to look through
that directory um and it's going to
filter only images and it's going to
filter only new images and just return
the list
of
that um here is the task that uses my
remote desk cluster and just to add to
it uh to answer your question there is
no special J ownable input or output
that we need to have and it's python
objects on our
end um yeah so here at the very top I'm
making a custom instance of the dask
executor um this is also the default
executor but here I'm customizing it
with a schuer address and what that is
is the number I pasted in at the top of
the notebook
um and then it has some hip dependencies
like we talked about that's just going
to be a list of these strings exact
versions um all set and here's how I
apply to my function C2 electron specify
the executor specify the
dependencies and um that's all so what's
happening inside here I'm downloading a
an input processor I'm downloading the
actual model uh these are just stuff
from hugging face you can go look into
these models if you want um and then it
will use Cuda the reason I've put it in
a conditional is so I can test this
locally as well without breaking things
um yeah so it's going to run through
each of the input images uh it's going
to pass them to the model and it's going
to generate uh a sentence to describe
the image so it's going to be a little
bit silly because it's a tiny model but
um it it it does work as we'll see in a
second run that
Cell last thing I have it is so this is
another local task it's just going to
write the description into that file
okay
so I come down to my
lattice um yeah what am I doing here I'm
just using those three
functions yes and uh the trigger like we
talked about so you pass a list of
triggers to your lattice uh the
particular one here is a directory
trigger it's triggered every two items
that are created and I'm not going
through the directory directory
recursively um it's going to be a flat
directory doesn't really matter you can
actually get rid of that probably um
okay so I'll run this the St in the UI
we should
probably uh no so it's triggered right
so it won't do anything until I drag and
drop so let's see which one do we want
to see here we got birds feeding birds
flying uh lemur monkeys let's do the
monkey with the pipe and we'll do um the
birds so if I pull that
in live demo please don't betray me come
over here to coent um oh it didn't like
that
okay oh there's a huge error that is not
good maybe your D cluster is Stone
probably think so
no well I'm just going to try it
again so if something goes wrong uh you
can do a calent
restart
uh sure you can restart extra hard if
you want to
purge
um so the resources will stay
up um and I'll just make sure that's
specified correctly at the
top okay
oops this is really cool I hope it works
um
okay let's do these guys as well okay so
put that
in cross my fingers refresh okay it's
running in there we go um so this has
been shipped off to AWS to that schedule
address um it'll take a few seconds to
actually uh do the generation and once
it gets back to us um we should see a
little description appear here in this
catalog file which is a master still
empty yeah the
moment yeah but then so if you have a
pretty large workflow running in that
spins up multiple gpcf just thinking
through use cases as well can you make
workflows that subscribe to like kopka
topics for instance y yeah exactly and
we haven't done the subscription um but
that even trigger could be anything so
we have exposed abstractions to write
any kind of triggers you want to have so
let me oh is it done no um okay while
it's going on I think just to kind of
even I forgot what are the triggers we
have in most of the triggers were
actually written by external
contributors as they see in new features
uh coming in so let's see the
triggers so I think we do have um
directory time based General uh database
based post I guess and SQL trigger on
our side but that could easily be
external to any kind of trigger that you
want to have and I guess so for database
be something like pass on the
postgress um to say the DB path the
table name and then you pass
on pass it on as this over here and you
give the poll interval how many triggers
you want to do any trigger
set yeah and all this is open source so
Farm by the way as well um obviously o
it's taking a sweet
time that's unfortunate this worked for
me
um this is me being bad at terraform
okay but one thing we can do is just
swap the cloud to local uh sure okay and
that should probably just work in we
have those things installed
local it should be in this environment
yeah local
and now if you just put on these
two let's
see and this keeps turning yeah what are
we bumping into I
wonder okay and you just saw how easy it
is to swap the same thing to run it
locally on its side and now this is
running locally and I guess this might
taking time loely because it needs to
download the model from hugging face on
the side um it was nice and quick for me
this morning I'm not sure it's still in
desk sure you swapped it y
okay uh but I guess um we could probably
just move on to the I can move on to the
next one yeah um and come back to this
once it's
done unfortunate that was my favorite
one
okay okay so the next one is a bit more
uh realistic example of shipping it to
not just a Das cluster but here I guess
we're using AWS batch on it side which
is much more important for computer
intensive tasks that can spin up gpus or
any kind of things on end so working
yeah so um I also have terraform to set
this up so I will uh do that as well
here
um this one's quite a bit
simpler and this workflow is a
interesting workflow because indeed uses
multiple is important to use oh one
thing is done I think you does St is it
y uh over here thank you no there that
one yep sweet okay the cloud one is done
so I think your it was just taking a
minute I guess okay yeah your notebook
should be
updated let's see what we got sweet okay
can you guys see
that it's not done a very good job you
could probably just use a bigger model
to get a nicer output but Google okay
that's it's group of ringtail lurus um
close enough a bird feeding its young
birds in the nest I think that's uh
that's pretty good
oops that's the bird eating yeah uh
there's a lemur one so I'm pretty good
at that two monkeys in a tree I believe
there was three monkeys
actually uh monkeys howling yeah missed
the third monkey um and the chimpan
smoking a pipe well it's actually a
chimpanzee but uh you know good enough
for a model that you can get in about a
minute
okay um sweet so yeah apologies for the
delay there um anyways let me spin up
the resources for the AWS demo
here I've also included a read me for
that uh the instructions here are much
simpler and don't contain typos unlike
the other
one um
I somehow think this is the one that's
going to a out pretty badly you think
so it is more uh the actual workflow is
much more complicated so if some a lot
more that can go wrong here yeah uh so
this demo the one that we're going to do
now is actually uses a string of tasks
to do it in so uh uh can you explain
what the workflow is over here uh sure I
probably have a version of it that I've
already ran um I think maybe maybe this
one yeah so this is a pretty complicated
graph that you see there but I think you
should probably zoom in because it's not
clear over there sure make it a little
bit no I think zoom in the graph I
guess yeah yep um so okay we can see uh
actually just so before I zoom in um
there's maybe three four layers of stuff
happening here and a lot of it is going
on in parallel so I have a bunch of uh
sections from a Wikipedia article uh for
example
uh
mcer um that is not the Wikipedia
article here we go uh so this stuff
right um these sections and I'm going to
my workflow is going to generate an
image to describe each of the sections
that I've specified we'll see that in
the code in a
minute
um but in the graph so I'm going to
batch those sections into a batch size
of two and then I'm going to spin up a
separate instances to do each one and
well I'm not doing it qu's going to do
it for me and you can see that happening
in parallel here so I think I have six
sections in this particular article six
or five so we have three two two and one
um these these branches will start up
simultaneously and then we'll work our
way down so this task will grab the text
from the section uh this will generate a
summary using an llm and then we'll use
that summary to prompt an image
generation obviously there's a lot of
compression happening so the images are
going to be pretty funky but just for
the demo um and then everything will be
combined into this postprocessor object
thing that I wrote just a little class
that's going to help me display it
nicely in the
notebook um and what's critical here is
that few of these things are pretty low
compute tasks so I don't need a cloud
resource for it so for instance the get
page section just uses a local dask
cluster as you can see on the top um
saying Das in and generate redu summary
uses a text based LM on the side so it's
not GPU intensive just CPU intensive so
I've attached AWS batch that spin up
guess how many cores 10 course or um I
forget it's in the X yeah some number of
course of just CPU alone while the
images is pretty GPU intensive um so
that spins up a separate GPU instance on
the AWS to run it in and these are all
spin up on demand serverless so what
that means is we don't keep on running a
GPU or CPU instance on it side so
whenever the task is needed it spins up
a new machine calculates it shuts it
down and goes to the next one so you
just use the
time and cost of how much of the
computation you're doing and nothing
else and nothing more um
yeah um all right so let's see if it
spin up in AWS badge all right y okay so
once you run the terraform you get all
the parameters that you need to pass to
your executor and this will be
abstracted from the next release you can
just do calent AWS deploy AWS batch and
you should do all of this automatically
and give you back the final arguments
that you need to pass in um and
eventually all the other ones ran as
well just for the record
so save myself the uh yeah okay um in
this case uh these are actually already
in there um but the only thing we need
is a unique S3 bucket and it's going to
be in you one every time so the only I'm
going to copy in is just the name of
that S3
bucket okay um so what am I doing here
I'm updating my default configuration
for AWS
um and there's a few things I need here
which are the outputs of my terraform in
this case I want to point it to my
actual credentials file like that um and
the rest of the stuff is uh already
there so what this does is updates the
defaults for the executor so that I
don't have to have all these fields in
every uh object that I
instantiate need to restart the coent
after setting the default as
well um I think it actually works like
this this yeah if it doesn't I'll come
back but um yeah so the tokenizer is
going to be T5 small again tiny models
um the the output will be a little bit
funky okay just for
warning um this class nothing fancy this
is just um My Little hack to display the
things in the Jupiter notebook um it's
just going to print out the images
you'll see what this looks like at the
very end um I don't have to do anything
special here I just use it in my code
okay uh this one down downloads the
model quick look at the workflow at the
electrons uh you saw um this particular
task is going to use the Wikipedia API
to read the text from the thing um it's
going to run locally nothing super fancy
there
okay um here's my first AWS executor in
addition to all those defaults I set up
there so uh I can just make one and say
in this case I want 2 GP pus here I want
12gb memory and kill it after an hour if
it's not
done um and then I pass that to my the
lighter of my two heavy tasks which is
the uh text generation along with the
PIP dependencies like we
discussed below this I have the heavier
one which is the generating the image
from the uh condensed summary that comes
out of the text model uh for this one I
I add in here that I want one extra GPU
with it as well um and yeah all the
other default settings will apply pass
that to my task with the dependencies
here as
well um the last task here just puts it
into a postprocessor
object um yeah it's going to run locally
nothing too fancy here uh the reason to
include this in your workflow is just to
um be able to cach the output here so I
can go back actually to my previous
workflows here like the one that
completed and um I should have that
output here so I could just grab this
paste it in and see the results from
this as if I had just ran it so that's
the reason I'm including this um local
electron in my
workflow
okay uh the main function just uses all
those functions to do what you saw the
logic that it follows here uh is
reflected exactly in the shape of this
graph here um just to kind of can you go
back to the lce over here so I don't
know how many of you have familiar with
uh air flow or any of those SS yeah so
typically if you want to construct a
complicated graph like this in air flow
it involves a lot of you know dags that
you need to Define in over here but here
it's pretty much just a python function
to take care of depencies and as I said
the main goal for us was to build a very
stable backend that can support
thousands of thousands of nodes on its
side so the goal needs to be to create
very easily thousands of nodes of graph
that you can have in to control your
system so yeah it's just an example of
you know three different parallel tasks
we are doing here but in theory this
could be hundreds of parallel images
that you're generating and everything
should be handled fall tolerantly pretty
safely on the side y so um yeah what we
can see in the this is the brand new
workflow graph corresponds to the
dispatch ID here D2 a and I guess he has
put in a wait equals true command here
to wait for the results in but if you
don't want in you can just dispatch it
close your jupyter notebook you know
come back after a couple of hours and
then get this dispatch ID and requery
the result and you should get a live
result of whatever is running so if your
status is still running it'll say it's
still running and give you back the
result of whatever is completed you can
do whatever you want and you can cancel
it uh you can redispatch it let's say
you don't want to use this model and you
want to reuse a different model for your
red summaries so what you can do is grab
this dispatch ID redispatch it by just
swapping this electron alone on your
side and what this will do is it will
not compute anything that's already
computed and just start from from the
point where it needs to start to so that
way you don't need to if you're using a
lot of GPU resource on the previous set
of tasks it doesn't need to recompute it
respin it up it'll just start from
wherever it is so these are the critical
things that's needed for high compute
because these are pricey computations
and you want to be pretty careful on
what are the things that you recalculate
and do on your
end yeah um and you know what's what's
cool about this is that you can just go
back and if you want to modify um like
this is using a bunch of cloud
infrastructure it's communicating a
bunch of information back and forth if
you want to change any of that logic
it's it's tied just to how you define
this function so you don't need to think
about um you know applying that on the
AWS side at all you just come back in
here um you can take apart this Loop you
can have uh you know less uh items in a
loop more items different inputs it
doesn't matter it will figure out the
best way to run it no matter how you uh
write the function here as well and um
if I wasn't waiting for the result here
right after you dispatch it you can come
back change some stuff up dispatch the
other version as well um this executor
is much more robust than the desk
example I showed you where I manually
set up the resources so in this case the
AWS patch execut it does everything for
you um it goes through AWS patch it
turns creates and destroys the instances
as you need them um it's it's uh yeah so
much less to worry about you can just um
send as many jobs as you like and then
get the result whenever you
want I this particular workflow is about
15 minutes of runtime if I look at uh
the last time it worked yeah 13 minutes
so maybe uh you just show in the I do
have the results from last time so we
can just uh look at quickly what we get
from it okay what have I done um I've
looked at mcer we all know mcer right
Crazy Stairs right okay uh so the
sections are his early life study
Journeys later life mathematically
inspired work
Legacy um here's a slightly disturbing
image I suppose uh apparently this image
corresponds to this very short
description of his early life uh where
he was born um his parents and their
occupations uh schooling Etc um this is
mostly just for fun I like this one a
bit more if you ignore the very creepy
person in the corner there um what does
this supposedly correspond to it's that
he went to Italy visited
Florence um son jimano I don't know
voltera Sienna and rello um impressed by
the Italian Countryside etc etc I don't
need to read all that morish
architecture is perhaps where all these
arches came from in the image but who
knows um this one's a little bit
interesting it it looks rather
stamp-like and the reason for that is
because uh the thing that it decided to
summarize from the particular article
section um is the fact that he designed
some stamps in 1949 so um that's a very
powerful word there and so it made the
whole image look like a weird nightmare
stamp um from
mcer this is quite cool I would have
this in my house I think it's just about
mathematical techniques and
art um and finally here's another one um
this is about a retrospective exhibition
um that took place in
in uh a museum somewhere and the reason
you see you're seeing this sort of
spherical Distortion uh is because of
this little bit down here uh it's based
on hand withd reflecting sphere there's
this famous photo of Aer holding a shiny
sphere in his hand um and you can see
his own reflection in it so dimension of
that has G given us this nice spherical
Motif here um in the output yeah the
pretty cool thing is I guess um we can
just sh this one which is while this is
running it's so this is a completed
workflow and I guess the end result is
this of this is the final thing that AR
just showed right now and what I do is I
just click to copy this entire thing
over here the result and I come back to
my notebook oh this is a running
notebook so I can just go to any other
notebook that I have in over here
and paste it shift enter and this
should let's
see oh it's a pretty large it is yeah
it's a bunch of images um you want to
run the uh display all method on that
object to get the pictur what we get as
I think you do out2 does that work in
the notebook if you index which one
sorry underscore also works underscore
is the previous uh return oh oh cool
okay so underscore do display all oh
sweet okay yeah it's actually the same
ones I showed so someone from this Bo
okay but the best part is that you know
if you're hosting this calent um on some
other e to Mission the server in itself
and if you're sharing the workflow
between multiple GL you can just copy
the result and look at it in his local
laptop just like that without needing
any extra setup or downloading anything
on his side and that's true for oops
that's true for any of the Midway
results for you to cash in as well so
these are a couple of warnings that have
um it's just the pro progress bar uh is
the output from the task so it brings
that in um but yeah but this is true for
any kind of outputs as well and this is
okay this is done with the CPU task and
it's going on to the GPU task right now
the CPU task I guess tooken how
long 4 minutes so I guess this is the
pretty neat thing whenever you're
combining these things you have all the
meta data and everything that you cash
over here
man not sure what I'm tripping on is it
the table I think it okay uh but cool so
this is a good example of how to use the
Open Source on our side so I guess in
the uh 10 minutes we have in we'll just
give a preview of the cloud version of
this which is a bit more interesting
with a lot more abstractions on a SB let
me just pause here to see if anyone has
any questions and yep so what does um
memory management look like on your side
I noticed that you're using Global
variables in things that are on
different executors do you just copy the
execution environment to each different
place that gives you access to those
variables oh so we serialize it on our
side all the global variables are
serialized uh on its end so the function
the pickle size of this function depends
on the global variables that you're
using does that mean instead of defining
requirements you can just import them at
the beginning of your
file assumed to be re can yeah on your
side but it'll just make your bloated
your call on what you want to do with
then yeah last question I had was on
dependency propagation so can you say
that so if you run one task locally and
the next one on cloud um and a depends
on or B depends on a and a has a certain
set of requirements does that
requirement set also apply to b or would
you have to independently specify that
the two requirement list that depends on
what you're using so if you're using say
py torch in a and you don't need py
torch on B you don't need to have it in
but if you need by torch and B you need
to specify this as well you have to
explicit yeah but you can if you think
everything in your task uses the same
thing you can just pass it to the Lattis
to say that hey all of this require all
of these things on your end and it'll be
propagated to all the stuff on your side
uh
yeah um any other
questions oh
I guess we can move on to the the cloud
version dude I don't know what I'm doing
over here is it you I might be this
little cable here okay just
yeah um um okay cool um I guess so A
couple slides just moving on the last
section is AAL and Cloud um obviously
it's developed by agnostic on our end um
so we have a cloud version of this
compared to the open source version it's
pretty much the same as open source
version that you see over there but
except you getting few more interesting
things out of the box so uh open source
is meant for individuals so you don't
have the concept of multi- tency or
multiple users using the same server to
send in jobs or whatever you want uh but
the cloud does support for multiple
users to send in all the jobs but the
more interesting thing is that um you
saw that over here you still need to be
aware of the fact that you are sending
jobs to AWS or E to instance or batch or
anything that you want to do it in but
what we provide in the CL is completely
abstracted cluster on the cloud for you
so all you need to say on your end is
hey I need 32 course of CPU on five gpus
of h00 and we provision it on you for
you from any Cloud that we find fit and
you can give constraints as well to say
that I need the cheapest compute or I
need the fastest cute I'm like maybe hit
I don't need to wait a long time I don't
care how much I'm going to spend just
give it to me and we pick the right kind
of cloud proper we want to have it and
we ship it over there so what you as you
say here it's pretty much the same as
open source except we have a new
executor called the cloud
executor um which will show up pretty
soon there yeah and over here the key
difference is that instead of adding
inde dependencies every time we provide
abstractions for you to create
environments as well so what you can do
is you can create an environment which
essentially abstracts a Docker image on
your side so you say that um as ARA put
it out over here you can say that hey
these are the PIP installs I need these
the K installs I need and pretty soon
you'll have custom images that you can
pass on as well and this will create a
complete Docker image and store it on
the cloud and you say hey my tasks needs
to use this environment it requires 2
CPU 12 gigs of memory and even GPU of
type T4 or whatever it is and you don't
need to worry about which Cloud it sends
into which place you ship it in and it's
our responsibility to have our own
cluster to ship it in and pretty much
rest of it Remains the Same on its end
um go ahead
um yeah so this is uh the same notebook
yeah it's essentially the same notebook
except really all I've done is to swap
out the executors here um so I have uh
let me come back up to the top so the
cloud executors like Sor said are fully
generic all you care about is the
environment and the resources uh there's
no like credentials to supply there's no
uh log groups and batch cues and stuff
to specify you just uh the only thing
you specify is what you want and what
you're interested in which is certain
number of processors memory and the
particular environment uh the
environment you also make yourself U
here I'm referencing just the PIP
requirements U file that I have
somewhere here um the python version Etc
cond pip packages you can do a bit more
stuff in here uh to uh Beyond just these
two but uh alas so as far as the actual
workflow code um what I'm going to do is
specify the new executors for my tasks
uh in this case I'm going to run
everything on the remote Cloud so I
don't really have local tasks anymore I
have uh lightweight CPU and GPU tasks
here so all the lightweight stuff I put
on the CPU
executor um and it's really just the
same code again use the GPU one here you
can see that I'm not I don't have
anything like dep pip over here uh
because I don't need to right so all the
environment stuff is baked into the
executor which is referencing this
environment that I have in my cloud
account that I've set up like
so
okay and I definitely don't have time to
run all this but the last thing to point
out here is that um this is a lot more
scalable than the OS version so what I
can do is I can dispatch nine different
versions of this workflow just in one
shot and I'm not worried about it
weighing down my PC or anything like
that um and that's exactly what I do
down
here so in this case it's CC dispatch C
dispatching it to the Cloud Server so
this is one of the main setup that
people have been using in actual uh
startups I've been using it on the llm
Siders you don't want to work on the
compute part of it so your for is not
actually infrastructure or creating
comput so you offload it to us and you
say from a Lambda function hey I need to
rerun my function with new set of inputs
and everything on the background is
taken care by us from spinning a gpus
running your code and everything and you
just get back asynchronous idas that you
can query back the result whenever you
want on your end
um maybe it's me sorry
um yeah and then you ask for them back
and you show in the UI
as come back over
to okay so I guess the cloud has a bit
more
uh you know fancier UI on that side so
AR has run in a bunch of experiments on
a send and I guess which one is the one
that you had it in and this this is how
you see all the yeah workflows that you
put in so here's all the nine things
I've dispatched um I've come in here and
added a tag to them just to know uh
what's what they all look about the same
depending on how many sections um in
this case it's only there was only two
sections um or perhaps only four the
badge size is two and so we see a
different number of branches yeah and
you probably will see the resource it's
used in so this one uses divided by 1048
on it side two CPUs on it end and
doesn't use any GPU and the generate
image uses four CPUs on its end and one
GPU of type
T4 um on its
end um and the environments that you
have created resides over here as well
so you can see that are has a bunch of
environments which contains different
packages so you can say that hey this
task only depends on scipi and whatever
it is and the other task depends on
multiple set of things and you can use
that environment exactly over here and
for us we just charge you exactly on the
computer that you use and we you don't
care about how many dispatches or how
many things you use and you have an API
key that you set on your end which lets
you control it uh but that's pretty much
it yeah that's about the gist of it um
all the the um apart from the
simplifications the way you work with it
is exactly the same yeah and you get to
share your workflows with your
colleagues so if you have a bunch of
experiments that you have done you want
to share with I guess few has been
shared with on our site to look at these
things um yeah well was helping me debug
this workflow actually the other day
so it's back this just this one thats um
but yeah so this is how the cloud fits
in so it's essentially the same as OS
but instead of spinning up your own
computer source you just ask us to do
everything on your side and you don't
worry about the infrastructure at all
you just write your code so I guess yeah
I mean in in the example I've I've been
running in the open source version um it
does look quite convenient and quick
actually but that's cuz I spent like a
day and a half writing the terraform
script to like set this up for me in the
cloud you would not have any of that um
if you want a GPU you just ask for a GPU
and and and you get it you don't have to
worry about um any of that stuff and
this also finished by the way but um
yeah and then uh what I've done is so I
stored all the dispatch IDs in the
dictionary here I also printed them out
just in case I end up closing this um
then completely independently whenever
they're ready I can ask to get result
and I can Loop through them and print
out everything I'm not going to go
through all these again one by one but
here's some cooler images I
guess Pablo
Picasso this is like lenon and Mona Lisa
put together this
one um ber mcre uh do you guys know mcre
the guy with the pipe painting of the
pipes thealist painter no okay that's
all right um his style is very much like
this but less uh less funky
and that's
creepy these ones are from the Wikipedia
entry for the inland taipan which is I
think the most venomous snake in the
world it does not look like this um it
looks doesn't look like this either yeah
AR is known for knowing a lot of
intriguing facts um some chinchillas
some nightmare chinchillas um vampire
squid uh ghost Batman um
Henry caval after a horrible
accident um okay well I guess we can uh
this is all so this will be all in the
repo um yeah can take a look at it run
it again but this is a gist of what
coent is and how people have been
essentially shipping compute code
outside of their local execution yeah a
commercial product or the open uh it's
it uses the it's built on top of Open
Source on our end uh but it's you can
just sign up and you can start using it
and you just pay for the compute uh on
own so there's not like a monthly
pricing that goes to coent as well as
Theus just you uh so uh the price is we
do have a subscription and then
orchestration fee on top of it but the
computer is purely on your end so we
don't upsell the computer or anything on
it um but yeah but open source is open
source you can contribute it um is hob
first
done I guess it just ended probably but
we had good issues on hob first as well
but yeah any questions any comments
thoughts perfect awesome then uh we have
a booth downstairs if you guys want to
meet and chat let me know um see you
guys then thank
[Applause]
you